blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
davidpakman Welcome to the David pakman
show I am Jesse dollar Moore sitting in
for David while he's on vacation listen
we got a problem with conspiracy
theories in the United States it's no
longer a fringe element that believes
that 911 was an inside job or or that we
didn't land on the moon or or any number
of disparate conspiracy conspiracy
theories yeah
the Republican party is in large measure
LED and motivated by
conspiracy theories
it is the North Star of the grand old
party anymore
and that is evidenced by their push
against science their disregard for the
Health and Welfare of their fellow
Americans and their families
and I want to talk a little bit about
Marjorie Taylor green but before I do
I get a lot of flack on my own channel
for talking about Donald Trump and and
Marjorie Taylor green and some of these
other Q Anon adherents and and
conspiracy Nutters I
and I believe it's important because
conspiracy is what led to the
Insurrection at the United States
capital
conspiracy and lies and propaganda is
what led to over 150 police officers
being injured some of them losing
fingers
obviously some of them losing their
lives
so to ignore these characters is to bury
our heads in the sand
and just hope that it doesn't happen
again I for one am not prepared to do
that I will continue
to talk about these dangerous
individuals in our country as long as
they exist now let's talk about
the lovely and talented Marjorie Taylor
green who is now suspended from Twitter
but still finds uh places to go to talk
about her insanity
real America's voice
I have been called a not a real American
many times uh this is the the what I
suffer through I've chosen this
profession and I'm going to be attacked
by Wingnuts that's what it is but to
have a network that's real America's
voice
it indicates that there are fake
Americans
and I've been called that anyway let's
get to this Marjorie Taylor green clip
where she Rambles for roughly a minute
and 45 seconds
incoherently at times so this is
concerning to me and that's why I'm
saying there's more research needed by
the FDA before the FDA approves these
vaccines because here's the problem Anna
Once the vaccines are approved by the
FDA FEA we are going to see the mandates
for vaccines ramp up far more than they
are right now they're going to be
mandated next year they'll become law in
some cities and some states uh Biden
would love to make it the law of the
land
Biden would love to make it the law of
the land that everyone is healthy and
their welfare is is attended to
that's her fear
she doesn't fear
that
um people are dying
of covet 19.
she doesn't fear that children are now
at higher risk she doesn't fear that our
hospitals are even filling up she'll get
to that here in a minute
she fears that more people will get the
vaccine
that is an unhinged
thought process
completely wrong again I'm not
anti-backs I
I'm being allowed to make choices
medical choices for them themselves and
their families
when you're anti-vaxx just claiming
you're not anti-vaxx doesn't get it done
Margie
you have to actually be pro-vaccine
there's not middle ground it's like I
don't know how I feel about it
when you go on network after Network and
you go on Twitter where you have to be
suspended because of your disinformation
campaign
promoting anti-vaccine ideas that's what
makes you anti-vaccine
and I don't think the FDA should approve
a vaccine that it doesn't seem to be
that effective especially with covid-19
raging all over the country at least
that's what the media tells us every
single day
all right I didn't mean I wasn't wanting
to stop and start this much but listen
two things here she's claiming the media
is claiming that covid-19 is Raging all
over the country
it is true we have statistics we know
what the numbers are we know what the
hospitalization rates are we know what
the infection rates are we know how many
tests are being tested
but to to to ignore the fact that the
reason covid-19 is outbreaking
everywhere across the country especially
in certain States Arkansas Louisiana
Florida is because of people like you
Marjorie Taylor green who are
encouraging people not to get the
vaccine
it is overwhelmingly
non-vaccinated individuals who are being
hospitalized and who are dying
still
of the Coronavirus
it is irresponsible
shameful this is shameful what we're
witnessing in this country the
mismanagement by Republican Governors
and being being bolstered by by clowns
like this
um that I've talked to local hospitals
here in my district and here in my state
yes the waiting rooms get full but guess
what the waiting rooms are full of all
kinds of things not just covet some you
know car accidents trauma uh other
illnesses cancer and so forth but
they're seeing about 30 percent of those
numbers being covered cases so while the
news tries to tell us the hospitals are
slam packed with coven that's just not
the case everyone needs to get back down
uh back down to Common Sense and
remember that you know we're human we we
can't live forever we are going to catch
all kinds of diseases and all kinds of
diseases viruses and we get hurt
sometimes
um so I I'm all for let's let's be
rational with this let's be careful
let's be cautious and let's not turn
into an authoritarian regime that forces
uh shots and arms of people that don't
want it
remember during the passage and debate
uh in the promotion of Obamacare prior
to its passing
remember the Republican conspiracy
theory and the talking point that Obama
was going to impanel uh a group of
individuals to choose who lives and dies
because of the ultimate uh rationing of
Health Care that was sure to happen
death panels they called them remember
that
also remember and note that there are no
death panels and we have Obamacare
but secondly that same Republican Party
is now the same oh death panels they're
going to be killing us that same party
is now who cares if your grandma dies
snowflake everybody dies we're human get
used to it
reprehensible hypocrisy
the the Stark lack of empathy
in Republicans is it seems to me to be
so widespread that maybe it's itself
infectious I contagion that needs to be
dealt with because they don't give a
[ __ ]
they don't care
about America or Americans all they care
about is their grip
on power
the other element to all of these
conspiracies that we're talking about
day after day after day is the fact that
Republican congresswomen and men are
whipping their their constituencies into
a frenzy
last night in Williamson County
Tennessee which is just miles north of
Nashville
there was a school board meeting
and at this school board meeting they
had medical experts testify
about uh their agreement with their
support of children wearing masks in
school
I'm going to read from the Charlotte
Observer article about the melee that
took place and I'm going to play a clip
of it it is
saddening I mean really there's no other
there's no other adjective it is it is
it is a sickening moment in American
history right now that we're all living
through watching the mismanagement of
this Health crisis at the hands of the
Republicans Governors all over the state
and then also your local municipalities
the Charlotte Observer article
anti-massacres threaten experts over
mandate in Tennessee schools we will
find you
the two-minute clip two minute clip I'm
getting ready to play post it on Twitter
by journalist Matt Masters was recorded
at the Williamson County Administration
complex in Franklin Tennessee after the
school board voted in favor of a
temporary Mass mandate amid Rising
covid-19 cases Williamson County is just
south of Nashville sorry I said north
hundreds attended the nearly four-hour
meeting where 30 people who were allowed
to speak
WKRN reported all of this
the board ultimately passed the measure
in a 7-3 vote
under the new rule all elementary school
students staff and visitors will be
required to wear a face covering inside
and on buses starting Thursday
a notice on the Williamson County
website States the Mandate expires
September 21
11 59 PM so it is a brief temporary
order to wear a mask
it's not installing an iron lung and
sticking your kid in it it's a piece of
cloth over your face that mitigates the
transmission of a deadly virus
watch this moment from these maniacs
[Applause]
[Music]
they are stalking a health official
through the parking lot telling him to
take his mask off
screaming at him we will not comply
it's a mask
you're a child abuser they Proclaim and
everybody's taking notes buddy keep that
little smug
it gets worse
they track around the side of the car
and they start accosting someone in
their vehicle with their window rolled
up
the same knucklehead in the T-shirt
sad day
in America
cops there doing nothing
[Music]
what is getting ready to take place is
an alarming thing because it's the
person who is trying to act as though
they're reasonable
keep it calm we want peace we want peace
who immediately starts parodying the
same rhetoric as t-shirt guy here
turning to the person in the car
explaining to them we know who you are
we will find it
we know we know who we are
public again we know who you are you can
leave freely but we know who you are we
will find you and then this
you'll never be able to be in public
again
the same people who were very likely
outraged that a man approached Tucker
Carlson in a fishing tackle shop and
said something to him peacefully
this is a melee this is on the verge of
violence so much so that there has to be
cops planted constantly throughout the
crowd all over the place watch how this
the rest of this unfolds again
[Music]
oh my God
keep it calm everybody back up please
everybody back up back up back up
please
I'm a parent
wonderful example setting for children
the parents
[Music]
oh yeah
fantastic
fantastic
this is
a melee
it is this kind of thought it is this
kind of behavior that led and I don't
think it's a stretch I don't think it's
a reach to draw a line between this type
of a lack of adherence to science and
research and data
and and instead
um a belief in conspiracy theories
I don't think it's it's untoward to to
link that to the Insurrection that took
place
it is a frame of mind
all of this is taking place these
hundreds of people screaming and wailing
and gnashing of teeth
over trying to keep Kids Safe
over wearing a piece of cloth over their
faces
inexplicable
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist then what they do is take
thousands of popular non-fiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample first just think how much you
can enrich Yourself by being able to
soak up an entire non-fiction book in
just 15 minutes I recently read A Brief
History of Time Of course by the great
Stephen Hawking this is a book that I
have been aware of for so long and other
things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction category stories
and a subscription is only about eight
bucks a month and you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
davidpackman I've put the link right
underneath this video
welcome back to the David packman show
my name is Jesse dollar more I'm sitting
in for David packman while I was on
vacation thanks David I appreciate the
opportunity
to talk to your audience hey you know
how uh Donald Trump ruined the red hat
for everybody except for Mega turds well
I mean it's a funny story here
Kevin McCarthy has now ruined the red
shirt and really taken the Maga concept
the Maga hat concept to a whole new
level because if you've ever been at
breakfast if you live in an area with a
lot of maggot people
uh we'll keep it respectable or I'll try
uh and you see across the parking lot
someone approaching and they have a red
hat and you keep watching to see if it's
going to be a a Nike Swoosh or if it's
gonna be a Maga hat
and if you've if you've thought about
well I don't think I want to own a red
hat just in case someone thinks I'm that
guy
I'm with you I've been that too
but Kevin McCarthy in response to Nancy
Pelosi calling him a [ __ ] or reportedly
calling him a [ __ ] is now selling
T-shirts on his website
with [ __ ] on them and then in small
much smaller letters the definition so
if you're that guy across the parking
lot approaching the the storefront all
you see is someone wearing a t-shirt
proclaiming themselves to be a [ __ ]
I'm going to read from his website here
oppose the moronic mask mandate with
this exclusive t-shirt
Nancy Pelosi just called Kevin McCarthy
a [ __ ] for opposing The Mask mandate
by the way
uh verbally and parenthetically here you
are a [ __ ] Kevin McCarthy if you're
opposing a mask mandate to keep
Americans safe and healthy
uh back to the uh website
you're a top Patriot and he needs you to
get this t-shirt to oppose her and the
radical left socialist and the radical
socialist left
yeah because Nancy Pelosi is a socialist
and then underneath here will you and
one friend order your limited edition
t-shirt today
really Shilling for for multiple
t-shirts to be sold and then here which
is a little bit more pernicious and not
quite as uh hilarious is this
fundraising tactic that has been
normalized across the Republican Party
platforms for fundraising if you've
given up on House Republicans and our
fight against the Socialists left
uncheck this box but if you still stand
with us leave this box checked and make
your monthly donation to bold Patriots
fighting back against Pelosi and this
socialist left and then small print make
this a monthly reoccurring donation that
is trickery it is not clear what is
taking place they're manipulating if
you've given up on the House Republicans
uncheck this box but if you're still
with us you Patriot then check it and
give us money on a reoccurring monthly
basis
a lot of people who give to the
Republican party as you can see it's
it's it's its default for occupations
retired there a lot of people are on a
fixed income
Donald Trump was just reported had to
give back like 135 million dollars or
something wild like that I don't have
the figure in my head
um but had to had to refund money from
people they were building who were
unaware that there was going to be a A
continuing charge so if you're
interested out there you can go get your
[ __ ] shirt and walk around proclaiming
to everyone just how moronic you are
in other
in other Kevin McCarthy news which is
not quite as funny as him selling
T-shirts uh calling themselves morons
Nancy Pelosi has actually called Uh
Kevin McCarthy out for something serious
I'm gonna read from this Insider article
Pelosi office rips into Republicans for
terrorizing Capitol Police after Trump
called officer a murderer now Donald
Trump still has his little blog his
little website where he issues
statements uh how does he phrase them
statement by Donald J Trump 45th
president of the United States of
America sounds real official on his
little blog
uh reading from The Insider before we
get to that though a spokesperson for
house Speaker Nancy Pelosi on Thursday
excoriated Republicans after former
president Donald Trump called a capital
police officer a murderer
as he continued to whitewash the deadly
January 6 Insurrection that he incited
quote the former president's Strat
against the U.S Capitol police officer
is only the latest in a long line of
vile Republican attacks on the officers
who risked their lives to protect the
United States capital on January 6th in
recent weeks Republicans have slandered
these officers as executioners and
murderers and insulted their
intelligence and integrity on National
Television spokesperson Robin Patterson
said in a statement enough is enough
Patterson said officers present that day
who have called out the partisan efforts
to downplay a violent Insurrection have
been subjected to death threats and
racist abuse no member of House
Republican leadership has bothered to
condemn this harassment or speak out in
support of these officers Patterson went
on to say Pelosi's spokesperson said GOP
efforts to malign Capital police
officers are disgusting wrong and a holy
unacceptable way to treat the officers
who went through hell to protect our
democracy from armed insurrectionists
the article wraps here Patterson said
it's long overdue for minority leader
Kevin McCarthy to get off his hands and
stand up to the members of his Congress
and party who have been terrorizing the
brave officers that saved the lives of
countless workers staff journalists and
members on January 6th it's no less than
these Heroes deserve and of course Kevin
McCarthy's office did not respond with
comment so what what sparked this was
this statement from Donald Trump on his
goofy little blog site where he said
this
I spoke to the wonderful mother and
devoted husband of Ashley Babbitt who
was murdered at the hands of someone who
should never have pulled the trigger of
his gun
we know who he is if that happened to
the other side there would be riots All
Over America and yet there are far more
people represented by Ashley who truly
loved America than there are on the
other side the radical left haters
cannot be allowed to get away with this
there must be Justice
there is veiled threatening language in
that statement we know who he is
listen
Ashley Babbitt was tragically killed by
police
while she was in
um
in an attempted overthrow of the United
States government
she endeavored to overturn a free and
fair election she attempted in the
middle of a riot a violent overthrow of
the government she attempted to enter
the house floor through a broken window
of a barred door
a blocked door
if she had entered who knows what other
insurrectionist would have made it into
the United States uh house chamber and
who knows what kind of Carnage what kind
of violence what kind of melee would
have taken place
Ashley Babbitt was an adherent of Q Anon
the same conspiracy theory group that
believes Hillary Clinton ripped off the
face of children and drank their blood
to imbue herself with the power of
adrenochrome or some other nonsense
Q Anon is dangerous the federal
government has warned that there is a
threat of domestic Terror surrounding
people who believe the theory it is not
something to take lightly actually
Babbitt
was not murdered
there is
a major threat from Q Anon though it
isn't just uh Insurrection it isn't just
playful ideas about wacky conspiracy
theories
there are other elements that have that
have human effect and impact
this headline is a tragedy
from The New York Times look I'm I'm a
father
and to
to think about the State of Mind of this
man who killed his kids
with a spear gun
because of Q Anon
[Music]
it's remarkable I don't understand how
someone
can go through with this and be
convinced of things that are so out of
this world
reading from The New York Times
surf instructor killed his children and
claimed Q Anon made him do it FBI says a
California servant instructor confessed
to killing his two children with a spear
fishing gun after abducting them telling
investigators that his belief in the
conspiracy theories known as Q Anon made
him do it the authority said on
Wednesday
the father Matthew Taylor Coleman of
Santa Barbara
drove his two two-year-old son and ten
month old daughter to Mexico over the
weekend and fatally shot them on Monday
according to an FBI investigator
in a nine page criminal affidavit that
was filed in U.S District Court in Los
Angeles on Wednesday the FBI special
agent wrote that Mr Coleman told the
authorities that he knew what he did was
wrong
but that it was the only course of
action that would save the world M
Coleman stated that he believed his
children were going to grow into
monsters
so we had to kill them
the special agent Jennifer Bannon wrote
She Wrote This M Coleman explained that
he was enlightened by Q Anon an
Illuminati conspiracy theories and was
receiving visions and signs revealing
that his wife AC
essed serpent DNA and had passed it on
to his children Mr Coleman described
himself as an inherent of Q Anon the
pro-trump conspiracy movement whose
followers hold closely hold falsely
excuse me that a cabal of Democrats and
Coastal Elites engage in pedophilia and
worship Satan the conspiracy movement
has been the subject of warnings by the
FBI and its followers would resort to
violence and they are right
the FBI was right the warnings were
right the Homeland Security Department
is right
this guy took his kids to Mexico and
shot him in the chest
with a spear gun
imagine the agony the death
the suffering that's not a quick that's
not a quick ending to a life
their father
did this
Q Anon is not just a playful
set of goofy thoughts
it's not
it is nothing but virulent
and sickening and dangerous and now two
children won't grow
to be adults
and this guy's gonna go to prison for
the rest of his life
a mother doesn't have her kids anymore
because of Q Anon
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
somewhere in America today Tucker
Carlson is alone
hiding under his desk
in the fetal position sucking his thumb
crying for Relief crying out to his
creator that things aren't good because
the census report just dropped there's
been a stark decline in the population
of white people in America and that is
go that is something uh that is going to
send him him and his white supremacist
cohort into a tizzy
uh reading from The New York Times this
this article a rise in Hispanic and
Asian population fuels U.S growth census
reports the United States grew
significantly more diverse over the past
decade as the populations of people who
identify as Hispanic and Asian surged
and the number of people who say they
were more than one race increased the
Census Bureau reported Thursday
overall population growth slowed
dramatically over the past decade the
growth that did occur an increase of
about 23 million people was made up
entirely of people who identified
themselves as Hispanic Asian black and
more than one race according to these
data the first racial and ethnic
breakdown from the 2020 census
the white population here we go are you
listening Tucker Carlson with your great
replacement Theory and your your your
your dog whistles to white genocide
which is a racist conspiracy theory that
white genocide is happening through low
birth rates and the promotion of higher
birth rates with people of color
real reasonable
the white population in the United
States for the first time on record
declined over the course of the decade
people who identify themselves as white
on the census form have been decreasing
as a share of the country's population
since the 1960s when the United States
opened up more widely to immigrants
outside of Europe that drop was driven
in part by the Aging of the white
population and a sharp drop in the birth
rate again
this was expected I mean some of these
these dips or the increases in in the
the rate of population of like Asians
for instance was surprising but uh this
has been long foretold in white
supremacist circles as something to be
fearing
that diversity is our weakness Tucker
Carlson famously said that immigrants
make our country poorer and dirtier and
Laura Ingram has long whined
about the changing demographics in our
country that nobody voted for no white
people are asking for this
this is good news diversity is a
strength racial diversity diversity a
thought
that it is our strength when people have
different lived experiences and they all
work together drawing upon the the
disparate lived experiences of each
other good things happen
evidenced by the our country the
progress we've made over the course of
the last 50 60 70 years
when things were not good in America
other news
[Laughter]
uh Biden
has been given a lot of press
conferences lately
Joe Biden actually called out Donald
Trump he used the phrase my predecessor
but Joe Biden called out Donald Trump on
uh the the
insane level of adding adding to the
debt that Donald Trump did and it's only
insane because of an interview that I'm
gonna read a snippet from from March of
2016 where Donald Trump claimed he was
going to pay off the entire 19 trillion
dollar national debt inside of eight
years and instead what Donald Trump did
was added about eight trillion dollars
to the debt rather than pay off 19
trillion
uh reading from this article Biden slams
Trump for racking up eight trillion
dollars in debt as he vows Democrats
will pay for their spending plan by
taxing the rich now listen a lot of
people get caught up in this debt
deficit and they treat the United States
economy as though it's a household
budgeting situation that debt is bad and
you must have a balanced budget because
that's what you do with your checkbook
there isn't an analog with the way a
government runs there isn't a
correlation between the two because it's
completely different you don't print
money in your personal household the
United States government has that power
now save the risks of inflation
it's manageable reading from this
article after months of negotiations the
Senate passed President Joe Biden's one
trillion dollar infrastructure bill on
Tuesday a day later the president made
sure Americans knew his economic agenda
would represent a sharp break from
president Trump
quote this isn't going to be anything
like my predecessor whose unpaid tax
cuts and other spending added nearly 8
trillion dollars in his four years to
the national debt
8 trillion Biden said on Wednesday here
in more full context are those remarks
from Joe Biden and they're going to be
fully paid for
this isn't going to be anything like my
predecessor whose unpaid tax cuts and
other spending added nearly eight
trillion dollars in his four years to
the national debt eight trillion dollars
they didn't even report to try to pay
for their tax cuts which went straight
to the largest corporations and the
wealthiest Americans
the Investments I proposing will be
fully paid for
over the long term by having the largest
corporations including the 55
corporations that paid zero federal tax
last year
and the super wealthy began to pay their
fair share they'll still make a lot of
money but pay their fair share
that means we'll actually reduce the
national debt improve our fiscal
position over the long run
my build back better agenda is fiscally
responsible the fiscally responsible way
to reduce the cost for families
in fact you're hearing Economist across
the board confirm this and you know as a
matter of follow-up Joe Biden has
promised that he's not going to raise
taxes on anyone making less than four
hundred thousand dollars a year so if if
you're out there and you make four
hundred and one thousand dollars per
year
good for you
and your taxes are likely going to go up
and that is okay
you have benefited greatly from the
opportunity
and the system that was set up
to provide you the the opportunities to
make that kind of money
for the rest of you which is the vast
majority of you watching
your taxes aren't going to go up even
today during this same press conference
but Joe Biden reiterated
that uh he's not even going to raise the
gas tax that's not something that's
going to happen
so uh the article continues the passage
of the infrastructure plan through the
Senate was a major achievement for
Biden's buildback better agenda and
during his remarks he touted the plans
for creating jobs and boosting economic
growth among other things he also used
this achievement to criticize the debt
that came from Trump's tax cut saying
that Trump didn't even attempt to pay
for them which is a fact
even when things were good prior to the
coronavirus coming on the scene
Donald Trump was racking up a trillion
and a trillion and a half dollars worth
of debt every single year so all these
Republicans out there the Mike Lees of
the world and the Ted Cruzes of the
world can zip it they can pipe down
about their concern about saddling our
children with debt now they can stop it
because you didn't say anything then you
passed overwhelmingly passed a tax
relief bill for Millionaires and
billionaires
with no regard for how it was going to
be paid for
how the hole that was left in the
government conference was going to be
made up
we just saddled another eight trillion
dollars onto our precious children
you scream
Chicken Little
according to the Federal Reserve data
the national debt Rose by almost 7.8
trillion dollars during Trump's time in
office during that time Republicans
approved a major corporate tax cut and
added two trillion dollars to the
national debt a measure many Democrats
and economists said favored the
wealthiest Americans they said that
because that is the truth now this is
what's interesting
in March of 2016
uh Donald Trump sat down with Bob
Woodward of of Watergate Fame who still
works for the Washington Post he gave an
interview
in which this particular segment took
place this this interaction took place
about the national debt and what Donald
Trump's plans were to combat the
national debt and continue deficits and
indeed how he planned to maybe pay down
the national debt
Donald Trump says we've got to get rid
of the 19 trillion in debt obviously I'm
reading it in my voice because Donald
Trump doesn't sound like me nor does he
he's not as coherent
Bob Woodward replied how long would that
take I think I could do it fairly
quickly because of the fact that the
numbers and then Woodward interjects he
says what's fairly quickly
Trump well I would say over a period of
eight years and I'll tell you why
Woodward would you ever be open to tax
increases as a part of that to solve the
problem Trump I don't think I'll need to
the power is trade our deals are so bad
Woodward that would be two trillion
dollars a year meaning he would be
paying off two trillion dollars of
national debt every year
but in order to do that you'd need to
not have deficits Donald Trump
certainly deficits of one and one and a
half and two trillion dollars aren't
going to allow you to be in a position
to pay off two trillion dollars in debt
Trump says no but I'm renegotiating all
of our deals Bob the big trade deals
that we're doing so badly on with China
505 billion this year in trade we're
losing with everybody
[Laughter]
and Republicans ate this hook line and
sinker they fell for it Bamboozled by a
con man by a Carnival Barker by a
grifter by a charlatan
Donald Trump did not pay off a single
Dollar in debt as I've already
referenced he added 7.8
000 billion dollars
to the national debt great great job
Republicans and now that we're we're
trying to spend some money for
infrastructure we're trying to spend
some money on stimulus to keep people
from losing their homes from to keep
people from being homeless
to keep people uh who are unemployed uh
afloat then they want to ask about how
are we going to apply for this
it's hypocrisy at its finest
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show welcome
back to the David Pacman show I am Jesse
dollar Moore and before I get started I
just wanted to say thank you before I
lose my chance and I'm not back here
again until possibly David goes back on
vacation and possibly maybe asked me to
substitute again
um I really have enjoyed doing this and
I've enjoyed some of the interaction
I've had with the audience I don't read
a lot of YouTube comments because
it's YouTube but I just wanted to say
thank you and if I am a flavor that you
enjoy I know I'm not David I'm not
really anything like David but if if you
enjoy what I do I would encourage you to
find me on social media find me on
YouTube and uh subscribe follow me
interact anyway thank you guys uh a
little bit of good news here related to
the Supreme Court some rare scant news
that is positive coming out of our 6-3
conservative Supreme Court and that is
the fact that Amy Coney Barrett actually
shockingly has rejected a a a hearing
and uh which solidifies a lower Court
ruling about mask mandates and vaccines
at the Collegiate level reading from
this NBC headline Supreme Court rejects
challenge to Indiana University's
vaccination requirement eight students
asked the court for an emergency order
arguing the risks of vaccination
outweigh potential benefits to those in
their age group
nonsense on its face and because of
legal precedent this isn't like her
charity they really have no they have no
uh other recourse but to do what Amy
Coney Barrett did the Supreme Court
refused on Thursday to block Indiana
University's requirement that students
receive a coveted vaccine to attend
classes in the call in the fall semester
it was the first legal test of a coveted
vaccine mandate to come before the
justices a challenge to the policy was
directed to Amy Coney Barrett the
Justice in charge of that region of the
country who denied it there were no
noted dissents from other justices look
it is
a nonsense political culture War BS
argument that Republicans are entering
into for Generations
for instance to immigrate to this
country you must have a slate of
vaccines
I went to boot camp for the United
States Marine Corps there were all kinds
of vaccines that I was required to
undertake
because I was joining the military
if you go to college
my wife in undergrad and her graduate
degree had to have a slate of vaccines
that's the same when I went to school
elementary school there are inoculations
that are required
this is a nonsense non-starting argument
that is only fueled by Republican
culture War BS
eight Indiana students asked the court
for an emergency order arguing that the
risks associated with the vaccine
outweighed the potential benefits to the
population in their age group quote
protection of others does not relieve
our society from the central Canon of
medical ethics requiring voluntary and
informed consent end quote they told the
justices seeking an emergency order to
block the vaccine requirement a federal
judge ruled last month that the school
had the right to pursue a quote
reasonable and due process of
vaccination in the legitimate interest
of Public Health for its students
faculty and staff the students have many
options the judge said such as applying
for an exemption taking the semester off
viewing classes online or attending
another University entirely
you got options snowflakes pull yourself
up by your bootstraps and make a
decision
the seventh U.S Circuit Court of Appeals
based in Chicago agreed it noted that
the Supreme Court ruled in 1905.
there's precedent for this again the
Supreme Court ruled in 1905 that a state
can require all members of the public to
be vaccinated against smallpox
Indiana's requirement is less demanding
the court said allowing exemptions for
students who object on the basis of
medical conditions or religious beliefs
an argument can be made that those are
appropriate exemptions certainly a
medical getting relief based on a
medical condition if you have an actual
medical condition certainly if you're
immunocompromised or
Afflicted with a myriad of other
conditions that possibly would qualify
you for that
religion yeah it's a little slippier
slipper a slippery or slope uh than
medical I believe because anybody can
make up anything and say it's their
religion
so
that's where we are and there are a
series of other cases that are rolling
their way through some even here in
universities in California that are
likely going to meet this same exact
fate
so republicans in Congress
Congress people in general are often
shielded from the rules that they put in
place for others often times
Congress people will skirt the law
sometimes they will act brazenly
as is the case with Matt Gates
and I have covered him on my channel for
a while now this case that's rolling
through this investigation that's
happening the justice department looking
into his untoward immoral Behavior with
children
which is an interesting thing since he's
touring the country with the Q Anon
princess
Marjorie Taylor green and save the
children is their their motto
well Matt Gates his associate Joel
Greenberg is now actually
cooperating with the government and it's
not looking good for Lil Matty Gates
ABC says Gates associate providing feds
Intel documents as probe into
Congressman continues sources former tax
collector Joel Greenberg is cooperating
with investigators none of this is good
news for Matt Gates they were thick as
thieves these two
sending venmo payments to underage girls
with with notes like books for school to
add insult to injury
as the federal investigation into
Florida rep Matt Gates continues into
the summer sources tell ABC news that
Gates's one-time wingman has been
steadily providing information and
handing over potential evidence that
could implicate the Florida congressman
and others and others and others in the
sprawling probe former Seminole County
Tax Collector Joel Greenberg as part of
his ongoing cooperation with prosecutors
has provided investigators with years of
venmo and cash app transactions and
thousands of photos and videos as well
as access to personal social media
accounts sources said again
not good not good on its face that Matt
Gates is a creeper
a sickening vile alleged pedophile
but also that this this man is the
leader of the Republican Party
a stalwart
example for young Republicans everywhere
and this is what we got
private messages exclusively reviewed by
ABC News potentially shed new light on
the process by which Greenberg allegedly
met women online who were paid for sex
and introduced them to the Florida
congressman and other associates
this investigation isn't just going to
end here
will likely be other powerful people
within the infrastructure of Florida
Leadership who are implicated in this
Greenberg pleaded guilty in May to
multiple federal crimes including sex
trafficking of a minor and introducing
her to other quote-unquote adult men who
also had sex with her when she was
underage Greenberg agreed to provide
quote substantial assistance unquote to
prosecutors as part of their ongoing
investigation Matt Gates should be
quaking in his boots
instead he's touring the country on his
Maga parade
trying to to whip up crowds into a
frenzy and maybe inside another
Insurrection the first of which he was
so fond
Matt Gates isn't the only Republican in
trouble in possible trouble
uh on the Senate side of the Capitol
Rand Paul
this headline from The Washington Post
unsurprising headline might I add Rand
Paul discloses 16 months late that his
wife bought stock and Company behind
covid treatment listen
senators and Congress people
I don't know that we should uh exclude
them from Investments like stock trading
I don't know it's tough I think to say
one way or the other uh definitively
it's it's a there needs to be more
options on the table and looked at as
far as what we should do to curb the
kind of self-dealing insider trading
benefit from the intelligence that they
have and I don't mean intelligence like
brains I mean like Intel on the ground I
mean they are they are behind the scenes
able to know things that are coming down
especially related to our current Health
crisis
knowing what is happening getting
briefings top secret and otherwise
they're in the know and if they use that
information to enrich themselves
they're at an advantage and an advantage
that isn't baked into the job you don't
run for Congress and represent a
constituency in order that you become
rich
Rand Paul Mr Noble Warrior of Truth
Mr Liberty
that's not what you're there for reading
from the article Senator Duran Paul
revealed Wednesday that his wife bought
stock in Gilead Sciences which makes an
antiviral drug used to treat covid-19 on
February 26 2020.
what a coincidence
what a shocking coincidence that on
February 26 2020
they bought the stock
and this was before the threat from the
coronavirus was fully understood by the
public and before it was classified as a
pandemic by the World Health
Organization
the disclosure in a filing with the
Senate
came 16 months
after the 45-day reporting deadline set
forth in the stock act which is designed
to combat Insider training so there are
regulations There Are Rules there are
stipulation there are there are rules
that he has stipulated to
that he is bound by
afford after you trade you have 45 days
to report it
for ethics controls
and just so the public knows what's
going on
and he waited 16 months after the 45-day
limit
experts in corporate and Securities Law
said the investment and especially the
delayed reporting of it undermined trust
in government and raised questions about
whether the Kentucky Republicans family
had sought to profit from non-public
information about the looming Health
Emergency and plans by the U.S
government to combat it several Senators
sold large amounts of stocks in January
or February of last year prompting a
handful of insider trading probes most
of those investigations concluded in the
spring of 2020 according to
notifications from the justice
department to lawmakers under scrutiny
remember Kelly Lefler
bar from North Carolina
all of this not good they are trying to
enrich themselves with the knowledge
that they have from their elected office
self-dealing in the age of trump seems
like anything goes
the senator ought to have an explanation
for the trade and more importantly why
it took him almost a year and a half to
discover it from his wife said James D
Cox a professor of law at Duke
University Kelsey Cooper a spokesman for
Paul said the senator completed a
reporting form for his wife's investment
last year but learned only recently
while preparing an annual disclosure
that the form had not been transmitted
that's a that's a very technical way of
saying oh yeah we didn't send it
we didn't email that we didn't include
that
it wasn't transmitted hmm
he sought guidance from the Senate
Ethics Committee she said and filed the
supplemental report Wednesday along with
the annual disclosure which was due in
May and submitted three months late
she also said Paul's wife Kelly an
author and former communications
consultant lost money on the investment
which she made with her own earnings
the purchase was of between one thousand
and fifteen thousand dollars of stock in
Gilead which makes the anti-viral drug
known as as remdessa fear the company's
stock was worth 74 listen to this
seriously listen to this this is how
they're saying they lost money
the company stock was worth 74.70 per
share on the day of the purchase and
Rose above eighty dollars in March it
has since
since though now that they're reporting
now that they've lost money on it now
they're reporting that they bought it
it has since fluctuated and was worth
69.84 on the day of Paul's disclosure
more than a year later so because they
made a bad investment had they had they
had they this stock skyrocketed and they
made all kinds of money who knows what
would have taken place who knows how
long we would have had to wait or if we
would have ever found out at all
disgusting unethical immoral use of his
office to enrich himself he and his wife
no good
no good and it is patterned and
practiced for Republicans to Skirt the
Rules while screaming from the rooftops
about propriety and morality and family
values and truth and Justice and the
American way
unacceptable senator Paul
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes you can try it for
free and get 25 off a subscription by
going to blinkist.com David Pacman